cómo interpretar la cancelación de las
conmemoraciones de una fecha tan
emblemática para el salvador y además el
negacionismo del presidente nayib
ukelele sobre el acuerdo
bueno es tu objetivo establecer una
narrativa nueva que borre la memoria de
la guerra y también la memoria de la
negociación que le puso fin sin embargo
la el sentimiento popular que se está
expresando en estos momentos en las
calles es que ni la guerra ni el proceso
negociador tienen que ser olvidados
cuál es el balance de este acuerdo en
estos últimos 30 años
pero los acuerdos pusieron fin al
conflicto armado
establecieron también un parámetro
distinto de cómo ejercer el ejercicio
del poder y además abrió la posibilidad
de contar con instituciones emblemáticas
como la policía nacional civil en la
procuraduría para la defensa de los
derechos humanos y otras entidades que
es necesario proteger y defender ante
estos avances de un fascismo
latinoamericano que está causando graves
problemas especialmente en una tierra
como la del salvador señor cañas según
el propio presidente bucl el salvador
lleva dos días consecutivos sin
homicidio como se está combatiendo la
violencia en el país a finales de
diciembre por ejemplo estalló un
escándalo que ha acusado al presidente
de tener pactos con pandillas
bueno yo creo que hay que ser muy
cuidadoso con respecto al tema de la
propaganda para la propaganda siempre va
a presentarnos la cara positiva y la
cara buena de todo lo que está
ocurriendo es indudable que ha habido
una baja de homicidios en el país pero
también es indudable que ha crecido el
número de personas desaparecidas en el
territorio nacional por más que muchas
veces las mismas instituciones de
gobierno se burlen de algunas personas
que aparecen luego en situaciones
personales y no necesariamente de
desapariciones pero lo cierto es que hay
todos los días personas desaparecidas en
el territorio nacional que luego
aparecen en fosas clandestinas